Listen, ah!
Salam aleykoum,
salam,
can you put me some menus?
What kind of menu do you want?
It's me, I win,
huh?
Put me on.
Are there any good menus?
Yes.
What kind of menu do you want?
Hmm.
me quickly.
And uh.
Do you want fish,
beef or chicken?
Hmm.
Fish,
fish.
Do you have the kingfish or the big fish?
You have fish,
sardines,
sardine or dell?
Anchovy?
No, there is not,
there is not.
What do you have?
So,
we have the normal fish with the isafo-biclic.
How is this fish prepared?
I want the typical recipe.
Well,
kinfish is mayo ketchup
and kingfish is king sauce,
that's all.
And how much does it cost?
The kingfish?
Four euros.
And the kingfish does.
Uh.
One hundred and eighty,
it seems to me. Amanda asshole,
you.
You think,
I'm rich,
I make a burger king,
but I am not a king.